foreign
I'd like to begin by telling you a story
it's a short story about a special
family
in 1960 a Utah Man by the name of Roscoe
Nelson a father of six
died suddenly of unknown cause
he was 43 years old
as the surgeon himself Dr Nelson knew
that his Progressive kidney failure
would ultimately take his life
but he was in the dark as to the cause
and he had no access to treatment
within two decades tragedy struck again
when four of Roscoe's six children also
developed kidney failure
looking back as far back as the 1800s
every generation in this family has been
struck down at a young age by a
mysterious and vicious disease
what could be the cause
fast forward to 2013. a team of
brilliant geneticists identified the
cause of Roscoe Nelson's deadly disease
it was a mutation
a single extra letter in the DNA hiding
in a dark corner of a gene called makwan
the mutation had been passed down from
generation to generation leading to
early deaths from kidney failure
the discovery of this mutation ended a
decades-long diagnostic Odyssey for this
family and many families like them
now as a physician scientist and cell
biologist at Harvard I have learned that
studying this disease and genetic
disease is like it is not only important
to the families they so tragically
affect
this work is a critical scientific and
research priority for all of us
why
because what my team and I uncovered by
studying this seemingly obscure disease
is a series of portals into the inner
workings of human cells gaining
unexpected insights into fundamental
biology
and best of all we uncovered incredible
opportunities for the treatment of not
one but many dozens of diseases
you see the amazing thing about science
the reason I love what I do is that if
you follow your curiosity it can lead to
Untold scientific Treasures
so in essence my big idea for you today
is
sleuthing
not the kind that solves crimes but the
kind that solves scientific Mysteries
what I call molecular sleuthing or what
is otherwise known as hypothesis-driven
science or curiosity-driven science
it is an idea as old as Aristotle who
was born more than 2 400 years ago not
far actually from where I was born and
raised in Thessaloniki Greece
ours total thought that at the
foundation of any scientific Pursuit is
formulating a hypothesis asking a
question that can be tested
experimentally
sleuthing of this nature is Central to
the scientific method and has led humans
to amazing discoveries
so how did molecular sleuthing help us
unlock the secrets of the vicious
mutation that killed Roscoe Nelson
well once the mutation was uncovered the
next question was how can a single extra
lettering the DNA lead to so much
trouble
my team and I got to work using
classical hypothesis-driven science but
with a Twist
our molecular detective work is now
supercharged by our ability to use
modern scalable tools and Technologies
let me explain
to understand how a single extra letter
in the DNA can lead to disease I must
first remind you of some basic biology
in nearly every cell in our bodies the
three billion letters of genetic
information the DNA is transcribed into
RNA and in turn RNA churns out proteins
which are the business end of what our
cells use to perform their basic
functions
the engine that turns DNA to RNA to
proteins Works tirelessly in each of 37
trillion cells in our bodies
so normally The Mach 1 Gene churns out a
protein called nucin1 which goes to the
surface of cells and forms a protective
blanket around them
we hypothesized that the mutation in the
Mach 1 Gene is generating amnesian one
protein that is not doing what it is
supposed to do
how could we test this hypothesis
a couple of decades ago when I was a
student this type of work would have
involved just a handful of Petri dishes
at a time
this meant that in a day's work I could
really only test five or six different
experimental conditions to see how the
cells responded
and then I had to spend several long
days at the microscope taking images one
by one analyzing them one by one to
finally make sense of the data
instead my students at Harvard and MIT
have access to state-of-the-art
computer-controlled robotic systems and
microscopes and artificial intelligence
powered software which enabled them to
analyze thousands of images all in a
day's work
as such we can study cells grown in
special dishes that allow us to test
hundreds of experimental conditions at a
time
in fact I estimate that our molecular
sleuthing to date has generated more
than 50 million images containing
information derived from more than 100
billion cells
that's as many cells as there are stars
in the Milky Way
and
in the end the vicious mutation that
killed Roscoe Nelson revealed its
secrets
remember we hypothesized that the
mutation in the Mach 1 Gene is
generating a mucine one protein that is
not doing what it is supposed to do
normally new sin-1 goes to the surface
of cells
however we found that the mutation in
the makwan gene is generating a mangled
misshapen mutant protein that does not
go to the surface of cells but instead
accumulates inside
this led to a new hypothesis is the
Newton protein getting trapped inside
cells and how does this happen
after some more molecular sleuthing we
learned that the misshapen protein
accumulates inside cells because of
another molecule a so-called cargo
receptor
thinking they're being helpful these
cargo receptors grab the mangled
proteins and throw them on board like
cargo trucks carrying a growing heap of
nasty trash with nowhere to go
unable to get rid of this toxic waste
cells begin to die leading to the
progressive kidney failure that killed
Roscoe Nelson
well now that we had insight into the
root cause of the problem we could also
look for a way to fix it
we went to work testing thousands of
chemical compounds across millions of
cell images and in the end we identified
one compound that could specifically
remove the mutant protein
after some more molecular detective work
we learned that this drug-like compound
can clear heaps of mangled proteins by
steering the cargo trucks the ones full
of nasty trash into the lysosome the
cell's trash disposal and recycling
facility where proteins get shredded
into tiny pieces
the results were amazing
after giving the drug to mice with
kidney disease for one week the mutant
protein had all but disappeared from
these kidneys
and yet our greatest Insight was not our
success in removing the mutant protein
from these kidney cells
we realized that our curiosity-driven
work had solved a bigger and much more
important puzzle
this mysterious kidney disease was not
so strange or mysterious after all
in fact we learned that it belongs to a
group of disorders collectively known as
toxic proteinopathies
you may have heard of some of them all
terrible incurable diseases like ALS and
Alzheimer's disease
okay now you can probably guess what
happened next
the incredibly talented scientists on my
team
here they are
they asked
thank you they deserve it thank you
they asked the next logical question
what if these cargo receptors what if
they grab and accumulate misshapen
proteins in different cells and organs
in the body
what about the eye for example
their curiosity paid off because we are
now learning that this newly uncovered
biologies operative in a form of
blindness called retinitis Pigmentosa
which is caused by a different misshape
and protein accumulating in cells in the
eye
in preliminary studies shown here at Ted
for the first time here is a mouse eye
cleared of Newton protein
thank you
and in ongoing studies we are finding
that the same may be true for different
misshapen proteins accumulating in cells
in the brain causing some forms of
Alzheimer's disease
in all we estimate that more than 50
disorders could be amenable to this
approach
so understanding one disorder has
unlocked a nodal biological mechanism
and insights for the treatment of many
more diseases affecting surprisingly
distant parts of the body like the brain
and the kidney
and so in our quest to save kidneys we
are now poised to save eyes livers
brains and more
and in our efforts to save a handful of
families we can now save thousands more
just think of the possibilities
if our work could unlock treatments for
thousands imagine what solving the next
medical mystery can do and the next one
and the one after that
and remember
rare genetic diseases are collectively
common
they affect ten percent of all people in
North America
that's hundreds of millions of people
all around the globe
or 120 of you right here in this room
and yet out of 8 000 genes known to
cause genetic diseases we have only
developed a treatment for at best 500 of
them
and this is not taking into account
disorders in which many genes conspire
to cause trouble like schizophrenia or
cancer or heart disease
we have a lot of sleuthing to do
and yet this is the perfect moment to
harness recently developed scalable
tools and Technologies and take this
challenge head on
and mind you patients and their families
are up for the challenge too
they're using social media to organize
and raise awareness and they are
becoming our true Partners on scientific
Journeys into the unknown
this is definitely true of the Nelsons
they have been our partners for many
years now
here's the next generation of Nelson's
our work has given them hope that their
children and their children's children
can live longer Fuller and healthier
lives
and they are proud to have ignited a
sleuthing Revolution
from a few
to more and more
until we have Precision cures for all
thank you